what about the other kind of factual
question of what what would have
happened if Confederate States won the
war the Confederate States had won the
war you would have seen I think a
separate country
and the South you would have seen two
countries and that Confederate country
would have been a smaller country but it
probably would have been able to defend
itself because it would have actually
gotten much richer than it was it was
poor at the time but through its cotton
trade and other things it would have
been recognized by Great Britain by
France by other societies and you would
have seen
um a southern Republic I don't think you
would have seen that southern Republic
dominate the continent the union had the
men and people and had the resources
but you would have seen a rival Republic
to the United States in the South do you
think they had interest to dominate the
continent to take over the the union
they had a foreign policy they had a
plan many have written about this they
had plans many Southerners did of
expanding into the Caribbean
which was actually more feasible they
did not have the Personnel to occupy so
much territory going out west if you
think about the amount of land that had
to be covered but they had the nautical
capabilities in Naval power and the
money
um to dominate islands in the Caribbean
and those islands were important for
their trade so there were many
Southerners who wanted to take control
of Cuba wanted to take control of Haiti
and the Dominican Republic and so you
probably would have seen Southern
Warfare in those areas
from a counter factual history
perspective can you make the case
that secession would have been created a
better world like if we're sitting today
and do Back to the Future thing that's a
session in this context if we put aside
the the the suffering and the loss of
life in the war that we would be in a
better world today just looking at
political climate or and can you also
make the case that actually this outcome
of the Union winning the war is the
better one I think the union union
victory is by far the better outcome
because I think what you would have had
otherwise is you would have had a slave
Republic in in the South that would have
encouraged slavery in other parts of the
world would have exported slavery and
would have necessarily been hostile to
many of the positive changes that occur
in the union the movement toward
Progressive reforms creating cities with
health codes and public education and
many of those things public education
really develops in the north as a way of
training workers who are being paid to
be better workers in a factory there's a
reason you don't educate slaves because
if you educate slaves they'll Rebel yeah
so don't you think there'll be a huge uh
pressure from the north to about slavery
anyway it would but I think the South
could have survived without another War
I mean I think the way that slavery
would have would have ended in the South
if it didn't end with the Civil War it
would have been with another War
I guess the deeper question is is it
better to work through your problems
together or is it better to get a
divorce
I think in this case it was better to
work through the problems not even
working through them together it's
better to work through the problems
where one side has the resources to
incentivize you to work through the
problems rather than leaving you on your
own to go your own to go your own
Direction I think the argument against
the union winning would be the argument
that would be made by those who believe
they suffered from Union power later on
so you could argue if you're a historian
of Native Americans
uh if you're historian of the
Philippines You could argue some of the
areas where this newly United Nation
coming out of the Civil War was able to
use its power to spread its influence it
would have been harder for the union to
do that uh if the union had to deal with
a rival to the South